do you
love jupiter do you love it so much you
could
look at it every day i hope so
because it just took the moon's place
and earth will never be the same again
why would earth no longer be a planet
why would only half of our world get
this spectacular view
and could you survive on this new earth
this is what if and here's what would
happen
if we replaced the moon with jupiter
overnight
no one is quite sure how jupiter
replaced the moon overnight
all anyone knows is that it's a
beautiful
and terrifying sight this
gas giant is 11 times larger than earth
so depending on where you were it could
take up a huge portion of the sky
but it's not just our sky that would
change
jupiter would transform the earth in
several ways the moon doesn't orbit the
exact
center of the earth instead it orbits a
point
4 671 kilometers off center
inside the earth it's called the berry
center
if you were able to combine the earth's
mass
with the moons the berry center would be
the center point
with jupiter in our skies the berry
center would shift and
i mean it would really shift
jupiter is 317 times
heavier than earth so the berry center
would move from
inside the earth to inside jupiter
drastically changing earth's orbit earth
wouldn't be a planet anymore instead
we would be jupiter's moon
okay so we would live on a moon
no big deal right well no it would be
a huge deal
oh hi i was just finishing a voiceover
for another stellar episode
you know one of the things i love about
my work is how it always feels like i'm
just having a conversation with you
the viewer and i couldn't do that
without grammarly premium
grammarly helps me write in clear and
exciting ways and
it gives me real-time feedback on my
tone i don't want to sound like a
professor
lecturing but these scripts aren't the
only thing i write
like you i also write emails and
grammarly keeps my grammar punctuation
and style sharp
and i can use it anywhere grammarly has
a browser plugin
mobile apps and a desktop editor so if
i'm outside and i want to reply to an
email while enjoying some sunshine
i can do that grammarly does more than
check spelling so say what you really
mean with grammarly premium
and get 20 off grammarly premium by
signing up
at grammarly.com what if that's twenty
percent off at g
r a m m a r l y dot com
slash what if all right now let's get
back to jupiter
now that the earth orbits jupiter it
would be
tidally locked jupiter's strong
gravitational pull
would cause one side of the earth to
always face jupiter
and earth's other side would always face
towards space
the earth would still complete one full
rotation on its
axis in one day it would also take the
same time
to complete one orbit around jupiter
you'd still have 24-hour days but a year
would be twice as long in its usual
orbit
jupiter takes 142 earth months
to travel around the sun in its new
position
jupiter would take 27 months
if you were to live on the side of earth
that didn't face jupiter
your days would seem normal as the earth
passes
in between jupiter and the sun but your
nights would be dark
and moonless but at least you'd have the
stars to enjoy
if you were to live on the side of earth
facing jupiter
your days would have less sunlight
depending on jupiter's position in the
sky
it could partially or fully block out
the sun
and every day you'd get to feast your
eyes on a
solar eclipse and jupiter would bathe
your nights in yellow light
since it would reflect 50 percent of the
sunlight that hits it
and that's really bright when you
compare it to the moon
the moon only reflects 12 percent of the
sunlight hitting it and
it's a lot smaller than jupiter so
if you turn up the brightness and make
it larger
that's one giant nightlight it doesn't
sound
too bad yet but that's because i've
saved the nastiest consequences for last
remember i said that earth would be
tidally locked
well because of that earth could
experience
tidal heating too there would be a much
stronger gravitational force
on the part of earth facing jupiter than
on the side facing space
and that would start distorting the
earth's shape
deadly earthquakes would become common
as
parts of earth were ripped apart and
violent volcanic eruptions
would destroy cities and pollute our air
we're just lucky that jupiter didn't
bring its other moons into our
neighborhood
one of jupiter's moons io is undergoing
the same type of deformation making
it the most volcanically active world in
the solar system
and it's not just jupiter's fault
the other moons orbiting jupiter force
io
into an elliptical orbit making the
disastrous effects of
tidal heating even more catastrophic
unfortunately for us the earth's orbit
would continue to be more like a circle
but earth's geographical transformations
would
still be enormous and you'd see
massive migrations as people moved to
safer places
and it's not just the volcanoes and
earthquakes that could kill you
radiation from jupiter would blast our
planet
killing or mutating all life forms
oh and one more thing jupiter's
gravitational force
attracts asteroids and we
would be right in their way it's
looking like you'd have to move
underground
to survive so as pretty as jupiter is
i'd rather it stay where it is
628 million kilometers away from earth
and if jupiter were to replace the moon
is it possible that jupiter would
eventually
swallow the earth would we pass right
through its gassy mass
well that's a story for another
what if
[Music]
you